[Música]
qué tal bienvenidos a canadá en las
américas café también conocido como el
castor mensajero con esas imágenes de
todo canadá de imágenes de vancouver
hasta hasta el otro hasta el otro rincón
de canadá
mari y no es aquí porque no hay nieve de
la época de canadá
[Música]
bienvenidos a que nada en las américas
como decíamos este es el castor
mensajero también lo saluda paloma
martínez desde nuestros estudios en la
ciudad de montreal aquí en el estudio
están luis laborda leonora chamán
leonardo gimeno y un invitado especial a
cabo y riquelme qué tal
muy bien muchas gracias por estar aquí
ya lo vamos a presentar un poquito más
adelante saludamos a toda la gente que
nos está siguiendo por facebook live por
youtube live for nuestro sitio internet
www.sprint.com
el programa la música y los proyectos de
acav y riquelme primer aniversario de la
deportación de luz y granados con
leonora chapman que nos presentó un poco
más adelante la corte suprema de canadá
que rechacé el reclamo de indígenas
ecuatorianos sobre la petrolera chevron
y de hablamos también de fake news para
saber si existen leyes o no en el mundo
que nos puedan proteger de las noticias
falsas o fake news fake news también
como también se les conoce y bueno
comencemos con los temas que nos
llamaron la atención esta semana louis
me dijiste que el calentamiento
climático particularmente aquí en canadá
te va a interesar sé si más utilizado me
preocupa
canadá se calienta más rápido que
cualquier otra versión en el momento de
su puesta semanas que el país se está
calentando de manera más rápida en el
norte en su terreno en su porción norte
del territorio específicamente en el
ártico de siegel ártico se está
calentando mucho más rápido está ganando
más temperatura
de canadá y esto tiene que ver con por
supuesto la actividad humana además de
los cambios climáticos que se dan de
manera natural desde el año 1948 cuando
se empezó a registrar la temperatura en
canadá la temperatura promedio del
conjunto del país aumentó 17 grados pero
en el norte ese aumento ha sido de 23
grados es decir la diferencia es muy muy
importante y tenemos un problema
evidentemente porque uno de los efectos
de ese calentamiento es que los hielos
del ártico se están derritiendo muy
rápidamente y es a ese proceso genera
más calor porque porque al desaparecer
la capa de hielo que depositaba sobre
las aguas impedía que el calor se
escapase hacia la atmósfera que esa capa
hoy no está with más débil directamente
ha desaparecido
entonces el calor que albergan las aguas
se esparce en la atmósfera y eso hace
aumentar aún más y con más fuerza y crea
un círculo vicioso que hace que a más
más de rendimiento más derretimiento
perdón más calor y esto tiene que ver
con la el cambio climático los gases de
efecto invernadero la actividad humana
los cambios naturales que no es bueno
que en canadá se ha dado un universo de
alguna manera al que se ha dado en eeuu
porque en eeuu ground niega el efecto
del cambio climático en canadá es el
gobierno que está impulsando su plan
para combatir el cambio climático y eso
de alguna medida también le ha valido
ciertas críticas porque han aparecido ya
voces que dicen que el gobierno saca a
relucir el tema de cambio climático para
tratar de tapar otras cuestiones
que tiene que ver también con la
discusión que se ha producido en los
últimos días sobre la entrada en
vigencia del impuesto a las emisiones de
carbono en cuatro provincias que no
cuentan con su propio plan para
contrarrestar el cambio climático y eso
tiene que ver más con una puja política
el hecho concreto es que la temperatura
está aumentando y lo sé
ya son visibles y van a grabarse si no
se toman medidas urgentes y ya habíamos
hablado aquí en el programa de las
grandes manifestaciones que se
organizaron en todo el mundo
particularmente de los jóvenes se
impliquen cada vez más porque la cosa
está peligrosa para el propio futuro de
estos jóvenes entonces yo hice una
acción a los jóvenes útiles de las
escuelas secundarias y universitarios en
todo canadá
150 personas se manifestaron las
víctimas por todos la acción que reiteró
y los efectos no van a afectar
únicamente a los jóvenes se van a
afectar a todos así que no solamente es
cuestión de decir se movilizan los
jóvenes del resto nos quedamos todos
tranquilos y evidentemente la cosa los
jóvenes decidieron movilizarse debido a
la inacción de los gobiernos muchísima
gente ha resaltado en los últimos días
el hecho de que los jóvenes se movilicen
bueno pero no se movilizan pero la
acción la debemos tomar todos o de aquí
a muy pocos años
leonora tu te interesaste en otro tema
te llamó la atención otro tema y
haciendo de la realidad está muy
relacionado con el tema que me había
llamado la atención la sense casa de
brando ha pasado donde hemos presentado
el caso de una pareja un matrimonio que
tenía una orden de expulsión este
miércoles de esta semana y había pues
todo un proceso que se estaba llevando a
cabo en la opinión pública canadiense
también porque el caso era que había un
niño de por medio
julián de siete años canadiense de
nacimiento entonces el gobierno
canadiense quería expulsar a la pareja
al padre mandarlo a colombia a la madre
a guatemala o sea separarlos y el niño
iría con la madre a guatemala lo
interesante es que un juez de toronto
ordenó esta semana detener las
deportaciones y dijo el juez james o
reilly dijo estoy consciente de que
julián sufriría un daño irreparable si
él y sus padres fueran expulsados de
canadá también habló de la deriva que
significaría la separación familiar
opción de su año escolar la ruptura con
los lazos sociales de este niño con su
propio país el juez también citó la
posición gubernamental del gobierno
canadiense dijo que el gobierno dijo
argumentó que la pareja no era elegible
para que se detuviera su orden de
deportación porque habían violado
repetidas veces las leyes canadienses de
inmigración lo cual recordó el juez
al hacer su al pronunciar su sentencia
de que eso era importante pero y
finalmente al final de la sentencia y
esto es importante señalarlo dijo sin
embargo eso no es cierto en este caso
donde la principal preocupación y
obligación de la corte es garantizar que
se consideren adecuadamente los mejores
intereses de un niño la sierra en canadá
claro que dice su momento exacto
entonces conversé con jorge orozco que
es el papá de julián y finalmente le
hice la pregunta le dije porque primero
me pregunte cómo se sentían y dijo
volverán a hacer es volver a nacer el
hecho de poder dormir una
porque hace mucho tiempo que estaba ya
sabían que iban a ser expulsados y le
pregunté a jorge orozco qué es lo que él
pensaba porque el gobierno canadiense
había interrumpido el juez dictaminó que
no había que expulsarlos y él fue muy
clarito y muy transparente dijo porque
tenemos un hijo canadiense si no ya nos
hubieran escuchado eso es casi casi
seguro entonces la cosa no terminó bien
ellos pidieron ahora la pareja pidió
quedarse en canadá por razones
cuestiones humanitarias la orden de
expulsión sigue vigente hasta que no se
determine si el gobierno canadiense de
inmigración canadá les va a autorizar a
quedarse por razones humanitarias
entonces estas están a la espera de eso
y seguiremos el caso examen seguiremos
informando sobre su destino de esta
familia pero por lo menos por el momento
están bien todos estoy un poco mejor que
la semana para lo que hizo el juez
yo creo que pinta bien para la familia
esperemos que bueno
que siga así que el juez no se va a
ningún lado
antes de pasar a otro tema saludos de
alexandra hernández desde bogotá
colombia
echeverría siempre está gustavo lucas
dice saludos de melo departamento de
cerro largo en uruguay saludos a pablo
que por su comentario debe estar
indispuesto y pablo está nos mandó un
saludo de leo el saludo de pablo s hola
a todos escuchando los sábados
peor que ayer dice pablo envió agua así
que te mando un saludo para todo lo
mejor esté así que lo esperamos
estaba tosiendo tanto pero buen fin del
invierno eso es lo más triste hay
muchísima la gente que se enferma y ha
ido muchos dando vueltas por ahí
no mencionaremos nombres no tenemos
leonardo tú nos habla de un lituano que
me pareció muy gracia voy a cambiar el
ángulo de información porque tenemos
según el cambio climático la gente
deportada no deportada y ahora luego con
una cosa así que me causó gracia en
realidad se llama siguen mantas stream
haitís y todo esto es porque se saca una
foto y le comparte en sus redes sociales
a bordo de un boeing 787 37 800 no el
maxi que éste no es un pobre hombre mira
el piloto copiloto tres tripulantes de
tres para de tres azafatas digamos o sea
cinco tripulantes en total y el en el
avión de todo para él a mí me ha pasado
alguna vez entrar a un cine estar solo
la sensación es extraña estar un cine
sólo lo solo y me pasó una cosa muy
particular es saber que estuve en el
cine bueno este muchacho viajó desde él
y está en lituania hasta bérgamo italia
completamente eso lo que decían era que
en realidad porque viajaba solo porque
la línea aérea estaba experimentando una
nueva un nuevo vuelo una nueva
destinación y no se habían vendido
ningún ninguno de los pies
porque nadie sabe si hay un viaje
directo no es una nueva trayectoria que
estaba dando
a mí me pasó una vez de viajar casi solo
no sólo totalmente como en el caso de
este hombre pero casi solo en un avión y
el servicio fue malo de todas maneras
como estaban implementando la nueva
línea el nuevo recorrido de la cadera
que tiene detrás está feliz está feliz
de ir en españa cuando estuve en españa
de bgc como 20 años atrás fui el cine y
me sacó a la entrada y dentro estaba
solo completamente solo y me siento
donde más me conviene donde más me
gustan las islas en la fila del medio en
el medio del cine paterna veces y tres
minutos tarde viene y me toca laboral
del acomodo me dice su entrada es
numerada tiene que ir a sentarse en el
l4 y vuelto el cine está vacío buen
hombre
déjeme sentarme donde yo quiera donde me
plazca
no no me dijo central me dijo me hizo
cambiar obviamente cuando aprendieran
luces yo que soy así de reaccionario
igual pero no entró y como 20 minutos
sabiendo dónde de haber comenzado la
película entró y te perdono entre otra
persona y se sentó en un lugar donde
estabas tú antes no no
me parece que se sienta el lugar
porque no era buena por salir de acá
un martes a las 10 de la mañana o sea no
mucha gente en martes 10 de la mañana
spain está más barato bueno yo en lo que
me llamó la atención es un juez de
ontario dictaminó a favor de una madre
que se negó a vacunar a sus hijos era
una disputa entre pareja digamos porque
la pareja está separada divorciados
el padre quería que él mismo quería que
vacunarán a sus hijos la madre no quería
que vacunarán a sus hijos y ella llevó
como como testigos incluso a personas
que son del movimiento anti vacunas que
además muy controvertidas las personas
que ella eligió en particular entonces
estaba muy decepcionada y decepcionado
el padre que el juez haya decidido eso
porque recientemente los niños habían
estado enfermos de una de una enfermedad
en particular que podría haberse evitado
con vacunas que la madre tampoco les
permitió haber haber tenido puestas
entonces es una historia que me llamó la
atención porque argumentó
para darles razones pues que ella si
llevo testigos mientras que el padre no
llevó testigos porque no los presentó su
lista de testigos a tiempo
con casos de sarampión que hemos estado
informando labores dijo
está muy vinculado con la signos que
porque creo que de hecho el origen del
movimiento anti vacunas viene de una
publicación fake news en la época hace
tiempo de noticias falsas de un médico
no sé si era falso el médico pero el
estudio que presentó para justificar el
movimiento el estar en contra de las
vacunas era falso
sí pero seguro que cualquiera de
nuestros padres si hubiese guiado por
una face y una o lo que fuera para
decidir si vacuna pero ahora el sentido
común también y aplicando el sentido
común en temas tan complicados como éste
y como bien decís canadá
y eeuu en este momento están viviendo el
resurgimiento de enfermedades que se
suponía existe no sólo en argentina
estamos viendo casos también de niños
que no se vacunan y que tienen
enfermedades que se creían erradicadas
radicadas completamente entonces bueno
me llamó la atención que no nos fueron
muy ligeros ni curiosos nuestros temas
de hoy excepto el lituano s
demás pero son temas que nos interesaron
en las demás vamos ahora sí con un vídeo
para presentarles a nuestro invitado de
hoy
[Música]
siempre viajando contigo en carro
hombres libres somos hermanos explorando
nuevos horizontes de gente buena con
lindos a rasgos conociendo culturas
diferentes a mí cuando la mente en ese
estamos vivir la vida porque hay una
sola mente viviendo el presente
[Música]
a
r
sí
también
si te dejaría
pero la verdad
estamos entonces viendo este vídeo de
kaui presentado por a cabo y
recientemente hombre libre es el título
de esta canción y es la presentación
digamos de este de este vídeo que viene
un poco siguiendo la tradición del
proyecto intertribal que había
presentado a cabo recientemente en años
pasados y este proyecto cuéntanos un
poco acá muy bienvenido de nuevo pero
cuéntenos un poco cómo surgió esta idea
cómo nació esta idea de colaborar además
con un grupo de música marroquí para
drives y cómo surge este proyecto acaba
de ser que fui hace dos años atrás de
marruecos porque surgió un proyecto con
una semana tal y nueve de mayo ni
mientras que el sobre ella su objetivo
era de mezclar de fusionar un grupo
indígena de canadá a huautla cuando un
grupo indígena del desierto que son que
la música que se toca allá del blues y
desde que son más a más
en agua todo eso del desierto
aquí
y yo hago como hago parte de un tambor
indígena de acá originario de canto
indígena está acá así que me surgió esa
oportunidad y cuando conocí esa es a esa
guitarra eléctrica
esa guitarra eléctrica y con el bajo y
el djembé yo desde una débil como se me
apoyaron sin alumbrado la ampolleta dijo
ping bingbing esto puede ser muy súper
interesante
hable que quede en contacto con algunos
músicos y a los meses le digo es que me
utilizar una canción surgió la a la
letra de lo que parece y trabajamos la
producción así la revista distancia y
ellos pudieron venir acá este verano el
verano pasado llegaron con un estudio
grabamos y sin una residencia en yanbu
el festival de la tradición de un tiempo
y la cosa se armó
y aprovechamos que estaban que estaban
aquí en montreal para afirmar esto yo
dije pero yo quiero ir al salsa a
afirmar la otra parte hacerla bien si la
vamos a hacer la demostración porque
esto hay imágenes justamente de montreal
y del desierto del sahara sí y ahí
surgió la oportunidad con ella misma son
disidentes que de ir a un choque que se
llama vistas pero music y yo me quedé un
poco más tiempo podremos traducir más
allá del interés cultural intercultural
mercader de ideas interculturales que
bueno parece una buena idea y además
usted siempre he hecho proyectos de
cosas de proyectos justamente
interculturales en el pasado
- dice que es parte del red sea spirit
singers que es este grupo de cantantes y
de músicos indígenas de aquí de montreal
porque le interesa está esta dinámica
digamos intercultural en la música
desde niño de niño si alguien dice lo
que montreal tiene lo que canadá tiene
como de rico a entregar es a esos
mestizaje entre pueblos originarios de
varios países también hay mucho canal
hay mucho inmigrante también tonces como
yo acabo de llegar de chile en chile
todavía la inmigración es tan nueva y
uno llega acá dice es palpable así como
hay de todos los países comida de todos
los países entonces creciendo en eso
aquí en montreal de fue lo fue lo que
uno cree ciones la verdad y en la música
andina también de niño y se música
andina con mi padre en en las calles los
metros entonces lo que es siempre
originario y de raíz
indígena siempre siendo también de padre
e hijo de padres mapuches chileno es
como que siempre estuve centrado en eso
si dijiste al principio me llamó la
atención la manera que hablaste sobre
una guitarra que escuchaste no de la
suerte que tiene de particulares evitar
es la forma como ya como la tocan es que
el sonido es tan diferente a las otras
guitarras webs no es la forma que uno
escucha una guitarra eléctrica uno va a
pensar música rock según así está la
foto pero esto es tocan su blues y le
ponen su visto un poco de distorsión y
con el fraseo que ellos tienen que un
francés o bien particular exasesor
derecha alan un poco más metálico pues
no tanto no tanto depende hay algunos
grupos que también que tienen su firma
que le cambian el sonido pero no tan no
tan metálico como un rojo casi pesado y
los músicos eran solamente de edad media
músicos ellos los dos países digamos no
dios dónde está cunita que son de la
última oasis antes de llegar el desierto
por la región sur oeste de marruecos que
ellos son de tag unit y allí
con todo lo interesante de dar a traer
que cada uno viene de una de una nación
diferente por eso se llaman exacto
bueno mire son hay una un saharaui que
es creo que hay un agua hay un magic hay
un
es visto bien pero hay dos más que son
otras tribus otras naciones y cómo se
dio esa conexión entre tu experiencia
acá y con los grupos de las primeras
naciones con ellos como envió ese entre
ese tejido por qué
esto lo que estamos viendo ahora es una
canción de mal de saia y ese es la
verdad yo lo pensé como un 5 boliviano
del altiplano de donde los andes
bueno explica que el 55 en un ritmo que
se encuentra en los andes' más bien
particularmente en bolivia también se
toca un poco en chile en perú todo eso
puede ser esa región
el tiempo del team fue así algún baile
bien de guerra la verdad es bien fuerte
y el tambor indígena de acá del power
también es día ya de marca y con ellos
entonces ahí yo dije
siempre me llamó la atención el canto
indígena
tuve la oportunidad los 15 años hill a
convivir con mi papá
y en mi hijo tenía familiar amigos
estuvimos en bloque de territorio ártico
y tuvimos una radio ya nos acogieron muy
bien porque mi padre conocía la gente de
allá entonces siempre estuve bien
anclado con esa cultura
y siempre me fascinó es el tambor y
cuando me dicen contacto por internet de
ingeniería y le presenté la canción aún
aunque sea siete meses con a un amigo y
bueno que no lo conocía en el tiempo
hice un contacto y le presenté la
canción así con la flauta y la idea de
la letra y me dijo que te voy a hacer
una canción para cantar una canción
indígena con exacto y ahí me invitaron
cuando ellos fueron al estudio estaba
uno de los integrante de míchel también
me invitó me gustaría ser parte de
nuestro grupo
yo dije pero obvio no pregunten dos
veces conjuntos de donde estuviste en
marruecos a tambor también es muy
importante el ritmo el ritmo de
percusión si ella también tiene un
tambor que se parece mucho al
los tambores de acá no se tocan igual no
son no son 100 de 12 ó 6 personas
sentados pero
le quiero mucho la atención y le llamó
mucho la atención en el tambor y la
forma como se canta también porque hay
una cierta región en marruecos donde yo
también canta con las voces agudas
y lo más lo más divertido de todo esto
es que
yo hice una marca de ropa que se llama o
sólo una excusa ni ná
una publicidad especialmente para mí y
la marca de ropa está
basada sobre la cruz andina que se llama
chakana en otros original tienen otro
nombre y si lo que a mí me llamó la
atención es que es detenido y ahora
chakana en todas las estructuras
mapuches están esculturas hay más de
aquello y está ahora cuando estoy más
aquí no indica una verdad también me
encuentras atrás y empecé y cuando hoy
empecé a ver bueno si vamos a una marca
de ropa de indígena nativa que marquemos
todo el mundo porque para mí puede sonar
como ese símbolo no un es un en vez de
separarnos decir a este diseño no el
estereotipo del tambor cruzado sino una
cosa que refleja y ahí vamos a mostrar
todo este tejido desde es maya de
guatemala
cuando voy agua a marruecos entrando en
zona más indígena donde están más
dígitos y veo la chakana así entonces
digo la mitad de la chakana en todas las
casas incluso por ello va a aparecer y
le digo a mi amigo o le colocó aquí
ahora lo único que quiero es verdad por
completo y me dicen no está mal tener ya
ok y cuando llegamos como casi bien en
la ciudad que se más de territorios
acoja la cola y ahí me aparece el full
la completa y le digo a un chico de allí
alegó que el símbolo estilizada esto es
indígena maya símbolo indígena está aquí
y qué significa esto
están aquí hace muchos años
en cuestión
a todo está conectado
entonces ahí viene mi filosofía musical
en lo que estoy haciendo también hombre
libre porque ama si quiere decir hombre
libre en el tema así en el idioma de
ellos
y tribal yo creo que el futuro es tribal
y lo he escuchado decir en varias
ocasiones porque el futuro extremo
somos todos tribus de una si de una el
blanco es tribal el indígena el negro
todos somos tribales y creo que estamos
por el cambio climático y todo eso hay
que los ojos están que se están
organizando mucho en lo que es primeras
naciones del mundo entero es tribal o
intertribal revaluar el primer ep semana
intertribal porque en él
en la nación indígena así hay una
canción que se llama hay un tipo de
canción que se llama intertribal donde
todo el mundo puede ir a bailar pero no
será el futuro será intertribal
bueno aquí tengo que continuar el
cortito gilberto martínez saludos de
nicaragua
johnny willy navarro y es el momento de
estar en sintonía en forma completa y
como hombre libre desde perú
es interesante proyecto aquí con las
comunidades andinas del maravilloso país
para mostrar el contraste de las
maravillas incas para allá vamos yo creo
que en julio quiero ir a perú a firmar
algo está bueno tenemos un contacto que
lo pasaremos bien en el momento y ya
está y esa casa grande dices
saludos chiquitos hola ya te conoce y
que lo puse en mi muro y aún así para
vigilar el que normalmente nos escuchan
[Música]
originalmente se me hace gracia
escucharlos desde granada españa
granada tierra soñada por la presencia
del claro ya que una última pregunta que
le deja a usted todo este proyecto todos
estos proyectos mezclados intertribales
en los que usted está implicado que le
dejan a usted con músico y como persona
experiencia conoce el crecimiento de
poder de poder viajar conocer culturas
diferentes y ver
creo que todo tiene una base concreta y
de si uno va a ser música o si uno va a
ser cualquier tipo de arte lo que sea
para mí tiene que tener anclado tiene
que tener una raíz profunda y que más
bien de poder yo he encontrado como mis
raíces y dije ya si voy a hacer música
que tenga o jara un impacto
grande hay gente que les gusta el diseño
que dice en tu canción en la que me da
el bus de todos los días porque como
tienen esa letra y recorrer quiero
conocer hombre libre por es por algo lo
hice también siempre me ha gustado
viajar
y conocer culturas estado por mi fuera
viajar mucho más y hacer esas pequeñas
cosas desde música para conectar para
que la gente dice oiga mira no tenía
idea dice sí porque alguien tiene que ir
a rescatarlo y se mira un poco lo que
estábamos haciendo ahora no se va para
eso mucha cosa a la música mainstream
está en otro nivel está en otra otra
faceta muestra otra faceta de la cosa y
creo que hay gran lugar espacio otro
artista que lo están haciendo muy bien
también así que eso es lo mío
los estudios mucha suerte en todo lo que
venga muchas gracias y entonces hasta
una próxima vez porque va a haber otros
proyectos que vas y si bien viendo tiene
un par de single bien bueno muchas
gracias hasta pronto y grosas vamos a
pasar ahora
yo quería presentarles un vídeo de
nuestra aplicación y ahora está leonardo
aquí sentados nuevo explicar toda la
cuestión de la aplicación de radio
canadá internacional que se puede bajar
por todos los sistemas que existan
en realidad son los dos grandes temas
los más utilizados estamos hablando de
la plataforma para android y la
plataforma para apple appstore y play
store son los dos lugares donde se
pueden encontrar y como verán en el
vídeo bueno en la aplicación es súper
completa se puede bajar en cualquiera de
las lenguas de radio qhana internacional
en el caso del español hay un acceso
directo para el francés y en inglés
porque son las dos lenguas oficiales de
canadá es para en el caso de cada una de
las lenguas extranjeras es decir el
árabe el chino y el español está la
posibilidad de ir al inglés el francés y
después a partir de el chino perdón del
inglés se puede ir al español y al
francés y desde el francés
al español y el inglés
directamente como no sólo directamente
si quieres entrar en español más derecho
eso sí es justamente lo que pasa si uno
baja la aplicación
uno puede navegar si tiene bueno la
suerte de hablar dos o tres idiomas
puede navegar en dos idiomas
quedarse con la versión en el idioma que
eligió no está bueno el vídeo este
nuestro vídeo en este momento live está
saliendo por la aplicación
como también las plataformas habituales
pero la aplicación se ve perfecto es
increíble así que creo que es una linda
manera de tenerla de canadá
internacional cerquita no y cómo se baja
uno tiene que ir al sitio de internet
nuestro y hacer clic en la imagen de la
promoción y de ahí ir a la práctica cómo
funciona el vídeo está la aplicación no
creo que se ve aquí pero ahí está la
aplicación
[Música]
así que es fácil de navegar y amigable
así que ustedes pueden ir y bajar
nuestra aplicación en cualquiera de las
dos de los lugares más popular oculares
bueno ahora vamos a hablar de los temas
de la semana leonora tú como decíamos
nos habla del aniversario de la
deportación de luz y granados y oye se
escucha muchísimo si están los dos temas
un poco relacionados con el que
mencionamos al inicio de esta familia
que estaba por ser separada y deportada
luz y granados no tuvo luz y granados
tiene hijos que viven en guatemala ella
vino acá hace casi 8 o 10 años que
estuvo viviendo en montreal trabajando
sin indocumentada trabajaba también
además no solo que trabajaba sino que se
implicó en movimientos
para cambiar las condiciones sociales
laborales de los indocumentados era una
persona muy muy activa y tenía tres
hijos en guatemala y mandaba el dinero a
guatemala a su marido lo habían matado a
ella la amenazaron las maras la
desgracia de luz era que ninguno de sus
hijos nació en canadá finalmente porque
hubiera corrido otro tipo de suerte y
porque se la dio se le hizo conocer
bueno primero porque es el si la conoció
mucho su caso en canadá porque después
de vivir diez años de pagar impuestos
como todo el mundo de tener ya una vida
organizada haber aprendido la lengua y
todo el gobierno canadiense le rechazó
su pedido de no sé si era en ese momento
no me conoce de refugio primero refugio
después por razones humanitarias y
entonces hubo una orden de deportación y
la policía canadiense entró a su
departamento con una violencia inusual y
arremetió contra ella para sacarla y
llevarla a una cárcel previo a enviarla
en avión y fue herida resultó herida en
un brazo en la cara entonces
por eso tuvo tanta repercusión en este
caso y eso fue hace un año en el mes de
abril justo hace un año hubo un
organismo de las bdr de la provincia de
nueva escocia de halifax que tiene
relación con guatemala que hacen de
muchas campañas por derechos humanos en
guatemala y ese organismo una vez por
año va a guatemala a visitar a
diferentes organizaciones de derechos
humanos y este año fueron a visitarla a
granadas a luz y granados entonces
conversamos con stacey gómez que es
coordinadora de la red rompiendo el
silencio de las marítimas y ahí pusimos
fotos de ella cuando están todas juntas
en guatemala
y ahí están y luz y cuenta y digo y
stacey cuenta un poco las condiciones en
la que vive luz y y que dice que
presentó ahora una demanda desde
guatemala con motivos humanitarios a ver
si la aceptan pero que la vida les
resulta muy difícil en guatemala y que
todavía las heridas que recibió en
canadá todavía tienen repercusiones
físicas y mentales en ella y justamente
la gente podría decirse claro están
hablando de una latina que deportaron
porque son latinos y no los medios
canadienses en francés y en inglés
cubrieron el caso de la luz y granados
funk formalmente porque fue un caso
particularmente violento por parte de la
policía cuando entraron de su
departamento
aunque cuando surgió el caso de luz y
granados periodistas comenzaron a
escarbar justamente a buscar otros otros
casos con con esta ley de acceso a la
información encontraron cientos de casos
en los que la gente se había quejado de
la manera que habían sido tratados por
los servicios fronterizos que a nadie es
la solución
entonces no es el único caso aunque no
son digamos la mayoría y la misma
magnitud
exactamente entonces no si granados por
eso ha sido muy conocida en honor a
entre otras cosas bueno pues muchas
gracias por presentarnos este tema y la
gente lo puede ir a ver en nuestro sitio
internet y escuchar la entrevista con
esta persona
gómez louis tú nos hablas de la
petrolera chevron
porque la corte suprema de canadá
rechazó el reclamo de indígenas
ecuatorianos de juzgar digamos de llevar
a juicio a chevron cierto y
específicamente dice mara juicios sino
de dar lugar a una condena que se había
sido dictada por la justicia ecuatoriana
que obligaba lo que quería obligar en
todo caso a la empresa petrolera a pagar
una indemnización de 9 mil 500 millones
de dólares por los daños producidos
tanto ambientales como en materia de
salud a las personas afectadas la
empresa texaco que era la que
originalmente se llevó a cabo la
explotación petrolera en
en el destino estuvo durante décadas
advirtiendo petróleo aguas contaminadas
y gases contaminantes que dañaron el
medio ambiente y la salud de las
personas hay que decir que esta
explotación petrolera se llevó a cabo
tiene un territorio que está aledaño a
dos importantísimas reservas de la
biosfera en el ecuador y
se logró que la justicia local condenase
a la empresa pero ante esa condena lo
que hizo texaco que más tarde fue
adquirida por chevron por eso la demanda
es contra chevron en sí
desalojo ecuador se llevó todos sus
activos entonces hizo que esto fuese
imposible y que si es imposible el pago
de esas indemnizaciones como chevron
tiene activos en otras en otros países
particularmente en este caso en canadá y
en problemas en el momento en el que se
presentó la demanda de esos activos
sumaban 15 mil millones de dólares
hacían que fuese dinero suficiente para
efectivizar el pago de la indemnización
se presentó un recurso frente a la
justicia canadiense y es ahora ese
recurso el que la corte suprema de
canadá rechaza diciendo alegando que se
trata de dos empresas diferentes que la
subsidiaria de chevron en canadá no
tiene por qué hacerse cargo de los daños
que produjo otra subsidiaria de chevron
en ecuador ese fue el argumento central
de la justicia pero los organismos que
apoyan la demanda dicen que el error que
cometió la corte suprema fulmina
escuchar los argumentos de ellos ni
permitirles a los técnicos explicar cuál
es cómo está íntimamente relacionada una
subsidiaria con la otra tienen todo el
esquema de cómo funciona el chevrón
armado y si lo querían explicar
justicia la justicia denegó la
posibilidad de que esa explicación se
llevase a cabo y entonces ahora intentan
proseguir su causa a través de naciones
unidas quieren que naciones unidas tome
cartas en el asunto y lance una
la especie de cobertura auspiciada por
naciones unidas para que en el caso de
que se produzcan daños como el que se
produjo efectivamente en el caso de que
se produzcan daños como el producido en
ecuador las empresas tengan que
responder no se puedan limpiar las manos
por una cuestión de derechos humanos
también claro pero si todos tenemos
seguros para toda clase de conciliación
simplemente natural que una compañía
petrolera también tenga seguro lo que
dice lo que dice rosa acción adora lo
que hizo no soy peralta perdón que es la
persona con la que hablamos en
definitiva es que las convenciones son
respetadas por los tribunales en la
medida en que se refieren a cuestiones
comerciales porque únicamente las
cuestiones comerciales son las
respetadas en este caso porque no puede
una convención que haga a la defensa de
los derechos de las personas que también
sea vinculante que también sea
obligatoria y que sea respetada por las
justicias de los diversos países ese es
el reclamo que a partir de ahora
intentan llevar a cabo a través de
naciones unidas muchas gracias
ya no nos queda mucho tiempo así que
vamos con tu tema la ciudad es
rápidamente pequeños estamos inundados
es lamentable como la ficción se han
tomado
el valor en internet y como estamos
expuestos constantemente ese tipo de
noticias falsas y en este caso la
noticia en realidad sale y a partir de
ahí hacemos este pequeño informe a
partir de la posibilidad de la creación
de una ley en contra de la fec news en
singapur y el problema no es la ley en
sí sino que probablemente y eso es lo
que dicen los que están en contra de
esta ley es que el gobierno abuse de
esta ley y que la libertad de prensa no
sea respetada no es cierto o sea la
línea es mandobles lilo y delgada y
están teniendo problemas por justamente
la posibilidad de que esa ese arma tenga
doble filo efectivamente hasta cuando
dejamos que salga hasta cuando no que es
lo que consideramos que sí que es lo que
consideramos que no si consideramos que
todo lo que viene de la oposición efe
muse
entonces ya no existe la libertad de
prensa vana y hacemos un pequeño mapeo
de los lugares de varios lugares en el
mundo donde hay posibilidades y no por
ejemplo canadá dice que no que no se
puede el gobierno no se puede meter en
eso que son las empresas
hacer una intervención facebook está
tomando cartas en el asunto para ver de
qué se trata y bueno hacemos un pequeño
mapeo en distintos lugares en canadá
singapur con lo que está pasando ahora
eeuu que bueno el presidente trump
publicó en los últimos dos meses más de
50 tweets con fake news o sea ser parte
del presidente imagínense la unión
europea rusia alemania que pasa en
américa latina según un informe de la
deutsche welle así que un poquito de
todo esto que está pasando con el tema
de la fec news en el mundo y pablo que
está enfermito pero que presentó un
reportaje muy interesante del que hay
que hablar porque esta semana se
cumplieron 20 años de la creación de
unamuno
entonces parece una entrevista con él a
luke y coti q creo que no estoy
pronunciando bien o quebrado lo me
explicó cómo tenía que decirlo pero no
lo retuvo porque no se nos dice cómo se
escribe ella es la presidenta de la
nunavut dunga big incorporated y ella
justamente la entrevista que le dio a
pablo le habla de todo lo que queda por
hacer en términos de
derechos de los inuit y en términos de
la realidad que ellos viven estamos
hablando de 25 comunidades pero por
ejemplo en términos en la escuela de la
educación hay 43 escuelas en todo el
territorio de nunavut pero ninguna se
habla ineptitud que es el idioma de la
gente de nutrición porque no hay
profesores que les puedan dar clases a
los niños en multitud entonces son en
francés o en inglés entonces está
invitada de pablo pues justamente
explica todo lo que está relacionado con
los avances y con los con los
exactamente con la creación del
territorio de nunavut más de 20 años
entonces los invitamos a que vayan al
sitio internet de radio canadá
internacional y vean lo que hizo pablo
al resto y no solamente habla su lengua
y en inglés y francés sino hablar
también muy bien español exactamente la
entrevista de pablo que desde allá es
sin habla muy bien inglés sin frases y
yo les presento nuevamente este
reportaje que es un reportaje largo
qué hizo nuestro colega de la sección
francesa de mont de marzo y que yo
adapte a las invenciones super
interesante las invenciones hechas en
este país particularmente aquellas
relacionadas con el invierno con las
comunicaciones con la salud o la salud
del espacio me imagino que está bien
el autobús o amarillo que tiene el brazo
y el stop
montreal en el color sí exactamente
entonces vayan a ver a nuestro sitio
internet hay tantas cosas buenas que ver
ahí en nuestro sitio
así que le damos las gracias ya nos
vamos a ir y yéndose en esta clave el
tiempo está bajo techo
hasta la próxima bye bye gracias
siempre viajando cambio en carro con des
livres somos hermanos explorando nuevos
horizontes de gente buena con lindos a
rasgos conociendo culturas diferentes a
mi cuando la mente en ese estamos vivir
la vida porque hay una sola mente